this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 19. with Echo Charles and me and
Jaco willink good evening Echo good
evening all right so last week I posted
or things last week it was a few weeks
ago a few weeks ago I posted something
from Gettysburg where I was talking
about
the indirect approach to things yeah and
the specific thing I was talking about
is that in the Civil War in in the
Battle of chancellorville Stonewall
Jackson
convince General Lee to take that that
he should take the indirect approach in
this battle he should take his troops
and walk 14 miles to get to the flank of
the Union instead of just doing a
frontal assault which was a half a mile
so either go right at them go right at
the Union Army or
come in from the flank after doing
walking 14 miles he was able to
conventionally to do that and once they
had the flank they won the battle very
quickly with minimal casualties so this
is the indirect approach and I was
talking about the fact that
it works with people
and you should use it 99 of the time
it's the better approach and it might
seem like it's going to be harder
because it's longer but ultimately it's
more efficient and it's more effective
and
then as I looked you know as I posted it
whatever no big deal and looked at some
of the comments that people wrote and
you know most people were like yeah
absolutely makes sense and then some
people
wrote things like
it's not good to be deceitful and things
like you shouldn't lie to your teammates
and if you aren't direct that'll hurt
the trust that you have so they made
these kind of comments and
I understand I actually understand their
misunderstanding because there's a
difference between leadership and
manipulation right it's
it can be seen like oh I'm just
manipulating you and one of the big
differences between manipulation and
Leadership is if when I'm when I'm
leading you I'm getting you to do
something that's good for you and good
for the team if I'm
if I'm manipulating you I'm trying to
get you to do something that's good for
me right so
that's one of the differences but
let me break this down a little bit
being direct with someone and that's the
term like you should be direct if you're
not being Direct
that's the term that they use you should
be direct with people and there's a
sentiment a synonym for the term direct
which is truthful like hey just tell me
the truth or hey just tell me direct
right so there's a little synonym there
so therefore if I say be indirect that
must mean that I'm talking about lying
and so I can see
that you can extrapolate and get to that
conclusion that what Jacques was saying
is being direct so he's saying lie and
that's not what I'm saying at all not
what I'm saying at all
and
if the way I mean it and the way it is
intended and the way it works is not by
lying it's by
look if I'm talking to Leif
and
if I'm trying to get him to use a plan
or I'm trying to we're trying to
establish a plan for an operation
being indirect with him doesn't mean
that I'm gonna lie to him it doesn't
mean I'm gonna make up like intelligence
reports that are wrong just so so we go
with my plan it doesn't mean that I say
hey if you already ran this up the chain
of command and it's already been
approved so we're going with my plan
like those are lies yeah and that's not
what I'm talking about
it doesn't mean I make up a timeline and
say well you know the target's only
going to be there for tonight so we have
to go tonight so we have to follow my
time my plan like those are lies and
that's freaking absolutely not what I'm
talking about
direct would be Leaf here's the mission
and here's the plan get on board with my
plan
that's Direct
being direct right
what does that impact have on life well
now life is being like feels like he's
being micromanaged you feel like he has
no input he also feels like he has no
ownership of the plan and all those
things are bad and when something goes
wrong it's not going to turn out well
and he's not going to do his best to
push through and make things happen
because it's not his plan he doesn't
have ownership of it so all those things
are bad the indirect so that's being
direct has a bunch of negative
aspects to it yeah being indirect if I
take an indirect approach I I tell Leif
what the objective is that we're trying
to accomplish then say Hey how do you
want to do it
and I listened to his ideas and I have
him present a plan to me and then I ask
Ernest questions that might reveal some
shortfalls of his plan if they're
already all these are indirect right all
these are indirect
and
it's not it's also not like a um
I'm not faking it I'm not asking you
these questions I'm not allowing him to
influence me with his plan to get him to
do something no I'm actually if he's got
a good plan I'm gonna go with it
by the way if he comes up with a better
plan than me we're gonna use it there's
no there's no lies there's no
manipulation
it's truthful the truth is his plan's
better than mine I'm gonna go with his
plan sounds good
the truth isn't like if I'm not lying to
him like well your plan won't work
because the intelligence says and I make
something up that's a freaking lie and
that's not what I'm talking about
that being said if my plan is better and
I ask late questions and he sees that
that maybe a different idea would work
better I'm that then it becomes revealed
to him and it's more powerful and I'm
not having to impose my plan on him the
direct method of imposing my plan on him
and offending his ego and implying that
I don't trust that he can get the job
done because I'm imposing my plan like
if I trusted him why don't I just let
him use his plan I'm implying that I
don't trust him so there's all these
freaking negative aspects
and I don't like it
and also I've been talking about for the
last six months especially on EF online
listen influence trust and respect to
get these things you got to give those
things right you want somebody to listen
to you listen to them you want somebody
you want to influence somebody allow
them to influence you you want somebody
to trust you you have to trust them you
want to get treated with respect then
treat other people with respect you
can't impose Trust on someone
in fact when you try and impose Trust on
somebody I'm gonna this is such a good
example
I'm trying to sell you a car and I say
hey just trust me I'm trying to impose
Trust on you does that increase your
trust for me at all the answer is no uh
I can't demand respect from someone it
doesn't work you better respect me does
that work how often you go okay great
okay thanks for telling me cool now I
respect you
and influence
forcing influence on someone because you
outrank them that's not influenced
that's just freaking orders that's what
that is so and the last thing is I can
bark at you and I can yell at you but
does that make you listen to me no
I mean you might hear what I'm you might
you might you might
the work the the noises might go into
your ears you can hear it but you're not
necessarily going to listen if I want
you to listen you have to listen to me
so that's what I mean by the indirect
approach um with that it is the
underground so let's get some q a it is
true all right first question this
question is not meant to highlight one
side is more right than the other
obviously every American has their
belief but this question is not about
whose side is right and whose side is
wrong
but to be a heated question I think
right now in America we have politically
charged climate where each side hates
each other each party has deep distrust
and skepticism and all-around cynical
view of the other party
for the most part lots of well that's he
says in parenthesis the most part but
where are you getting this from where
you're getting this from if you go look
at social media right if you go look at
social media and even not just social
media media because the media wants you
to watch what they're making and you
only want to watch what they're making
if it seems a little bit exciting and
the only thing that's exciting is
emotions and hatred and Chaos so that's
what we're selling so that's what's
clicking and I work with companies All
Over America all the time and the
companies are out there making things
happen and the workers you know what
they're concerned about you know what
the employees are concerned with you
know what the leadership is concerned
with they're concerned with
improving their market share and
delivering good stuff to the to the
consumers that's what the vast that's
that's most people that's for the most
part
yeah yeah
and that's a critical point right there
easy to forget too by the way explain
this to people all the time especially
you know uh talking to Ben Shapiro like
in his mind it's Mayhem oh yeah because
that dude's at Point Blank you know uh
Ground Zero for political
activities yeah and thoughts and
comments and hostility he's he's ground
zero that's all he sees all day long oh
yeah I can't even imagine what the world
looks like through his eyes falling
apart and even then even Ben Shapiro
kind of someone's you know these even
then it's the majority of it if not all
of it is from the Internet or the news
oh yeah you know it's and it's that's
the way it looks you know
um when you look at Rachel Maddow it's
the same thing she's at Ground Zero for
all this stuff so it doesn't matter you
can pick your ground zero and the way
the world looks through their lens is
like freaking total Mayhem oh yeah total
freaking Mayhem oh yeah and what do they
talk about they that's what they talk
about is total freaking Mayhem so this
individual that's writing this question
they're looking at the world and going
oh my God I got Rachel Maddow on one
side and I got freaking Sean Hannity on
the other side and that's the world
chaos yep
but in in in the spirit of that just
trying to maybe start from a place of
more accuracy if even possible I don't
know we all live different lives I get
it but yeah let's say you exclude that
let's say you exclude any political news
and then exclude social media in the
internet okay thing exclude that and
then when you go outside you go to work
you go to the store post office Jiu
Jitsu lifting at the gym or whatever bro
there's nobody yelling anymore
I was like bro we just there's you know
a thousand people at Victory MMA and
fitness I haven't heard anybody talk
about any of this stuff yeah oh yeah in
fact like you can drive on the street
and you can see like someone's bumper
sticker I support buy it in or I support
Trump or whatever and you're almost like
bro calm down over there we're over here
just kind of crazy you know and you're
over here representing the thing is it
doesn't everyone has a right to do that
for sure but I'm saying that's how mild
it is in real life outside of the
internet where you can see someone
expressing themselves and they seem out
of place yeah that's how it is in real
life quote unquote again depends on
where you live depends what you do for a
career if you're Ben Shapiro you go to
the office and the guys and you know it
I get it but day to day man I don't know
this simply doesn't seem true outside of
the internet yeah but we'll let's
continue with the question I cut you off
because it doesn't mean that it's not
true yeah because obviously there are
parts of the parts of the the world and
parts of the country
on those two left and right flanks that
are freaking fired up yeah and and
regard and each party has deep distress
and skepticism and also the thing is the
internet is a real part of life that's
the thing yeah so yeah people are fired
up there's a lot to do with the internet
but at the end of the day they're fired
up yeah you know so okay so we'll see
the question okay so the question
continues lots of people in these
parties assume the worst of
the other and do not fill information
gaps with trust and not just the
politicians themselves but also the
American population obviously these are
bad dispositions to hold and have
already produced violence the last year
in America has been crazy and violent
for a myriad of political politically
charged reasons the question I have is
do you foresee a Civil War in America
anytime in the near future and if not
full-blown Civil War perhaps pockets of
conflict here and there across the
country
we've already seen things such as
autonomous zones which have become
militarized and violent and almost and
almost seem like a succession
so that's a that's a logical question
right now um you know you're seeing all
this like like like we just talked about
you're seeing all this extremism on the
left and on the right and you think well
geez if that's what's happening could we
could we be heading for a civil war
first of all we've been through a lot
worse
a lot worse first I mean the actual
Civil War
you know we've been through an actual
Civil War where hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of Americans were killed
going so that's a the huge example but I
mean even you go back to the late 60s
early 70s and you had the weather
underground and the Black Liberation
Army and the city and East liberation
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
at Jocko underground.com and we'll get
you taken care of until then
you mobilized
Underground